it's just us it's just past 10 GMT and
we start with the conflict in Ukraine
Russia says its Navy has carried out
what it calls live fire exercises in the
Black Sea according to his defense
Ministry it conducted combat drills and
practiced detaining ships in the
northwest of the sea near Ukraine
earlier this week the Kremlin warned
against ships sailing in the Black Sea
it said any vessel heading to Ukraine
would be treated as a threat that means
potentially transporting military cargo
Julia shop of Oliver joins us from
Moscow on this Julia in we in the past
few moments Russian officials have been
responding to Ukraine's threats against
Russian ships in the Black Sea now this
has just happened new development are
you hearing what are you hearing about
this
yeah just Italian development indeed and
well we're all remember that utter
Russia pulled out of the green deal at
the ministry of Defense announced that
starting from July the 20th all vessels
falling through the Black Sea to
Ukrainian ports who would be perceived
by Russia as potential carriers of
military cargo therefore all ships
sailing to Ukrainian pools would be
considered involved in the conflicts and
supporting Ukraine and now we've got
reports that the Black Sea Fleet also
conducted military drills as they say to
isolate the area marked by Russia as the
era temporarily closed to navigation and
of course the Kremlin did indeed comment
on key of statements that ship's going
to to Russia through the Black Sea would
be considered military targets for
Ukraine too and Dimitri peskov called
those statements dangerous because that
can endanger navigation in the uh Black
Sea and he also said that various
Russian departments are now developing
recommendations how to minimize the
danger to all those ships in the Black
Sea so basically what we see Russia
continues showing its capabilities
holding exercises in different areas and
at the same time participating in the
Ukrainian conflict okay talk to me a
little bit more about these exercises
because Russia of course in this rapid
sequence of events first says that
Ukrainian ships could be considered a
Target and then holds very public very
visible exercises where they practice
detaining and destroying ships what's
the message there
well basically the message is that
Russia wants to keep its word and
basically it's showing of the whole
world it's military might because not
just the drills in the Black Sea that
we've been reporting but also other
military drills involving uh Chinese the
Chinese Fleet are taking place in the
Sea of Japan right now so basically the
the forces are fulfilling their tasks
and trying to basically carry out some
military exercises and destroying some
mock enemy as they as they call it so
potentially Russia Russia is going to
say that it is serious it is being
serious and that the green deal well it
is important and the whole world has to
to listen to it and try to basically to
and yeah the whole world has to listen
to it all of this has been triggered by
the fact that Russia a few days ago
pulled out of the grain deal with
Ukraine this deal mediated by the U.N
and turkey that allows uh Ukraine and
Russia in the deal to export grain and
fertilizer now Vladimir Putin
interestingly is leaving the door open
to actually Reviving this deal but on
certain conditions
well yes uh President Putin uh well just
said that the grain deal is not doomed
it can be resumed if Russia's demands
are met and uh taken into account and
implemented uh basically Putin reminded
that Western countries had to lift
sanctions on Russia's grain and
fertilizers supplies to the world
markets and also he said that the West
has to remove some some obstacles for
Russia's Banks and financial
institutions
that provide services for the green
supplies and within the grain deal and
that connection to the Swift payment
system as well so the resumption of
supplies of components for agricultural
Machinery is also important for Russia
plus Russia wants to solve questions of
insurance of its ships as well as to
resume work of the Italian Adesa ammonia
pipeline as a remember part of that
pipeline was blown up in the in June at
the end of June on the Ukrainian
territory so we understand that many
here say that the green deal
negotiations will continue in the near
future as so many parties are involved
our interests and interested in in the
uh grain deal to to uh well to to to in
the green deal to exist
Julia shop of Oliver reporting from
Moscow thank you very much